there was constant man accused of
kidnapping Jamie Claus and then killing
the teenagers parents he's apparently
speaking out from jail the man has been
identified as Jake Patterson he called
reporter jennifer mayerle she's from our
Minneapolis station that's WCCO after
Jennifer wrote him a letter the phone
call came over the weekend as causes
hometown helps her readjust Jamie yuccas
has been closely following this case and
she's in Los Angeles with more on this
story Jamie good morning to you good
morning the call WCCO received from jail
lasted only a few minutes during that
time the man who said he was Jake
Patterson answered questions about the
case when asked whether he had regrets
he said of course but would not
elaborate less than two weeks before
Jake Patterson is set to be arraigned a
man identifying himself as the 21 year
old is revealing why he confessed to
kidnapping Jamie Claus and murdering her
parents reporter jennifer mayerle got
the call from the Polk County Jail
Friday the caller said he wants to talk
to cost but knows he can't according to
investigators Patterson confessed to
breaking into Casas home last October
and shooting both of her parents in the
head he kept her at his remote cabin
often forcing her to stay under the bed
for several hours at a time Kloss was
able to escape in January flagging down
a woman walking her dog on the same day
Patterson apparently spoke to the
reporter another kidnapping victim
Elizabeth Smart addressed clausus
hometown about coming together to heal
smart encouraged the community to
respect clauses privacy and avoid tough
questions to better allow her to settle
in back home and I find it inspiring to
see so many of you here tonight in
support of Jayme in moving forward and
in reclaiming all of your lives because
this has touched so many people
Klaus has been living with her aunt as
she works to rebuild her life
Patterson faces charges of first-degree
intentional homicide kidnapping and
armed burglary he'll be back in court on
March 27th Nora
Lori Jamie mom thank you it's really
interesting that he would reach out to
her this way you know the Claus family
told us at the beginning that they were
going to shield her from all the
coverages as Jamie alluded to there I
hope they're still doing that because it
would be so drawing I would think for
her to hear this guy speaking I love you
and all the things that he says
Elizabeth Smart there she is terrific
about having been able to go through
this and helps turn her life around yeah